Romeo and Juliet Bonnie and Clyde peanut
butter and jelly battleborn and over
what there are some things that just
work as a pairing but now battleborn is
dropping in price by twenty dollars on
the same day that overwatch goes on sale
and people who bought the game at full
price aren't pleased I'm Kate and this
is your colorful mobile light with a
host of interesting characters news
update humorous retailers including
amazon and gamestop are now selling
Borderlands developer gearbox software's
new shooter battleborn for only forty
dollars the price drop comes less than a
month after the game arrived on May
third the timing is also interesting in
that the day the game dropped in price
is also the day when blizzards own hero
based shooter overwatch went on sales as
for overwatch if the game's highly
successful beta is any indication it
could become a top seller for Blizzard
the open beta which ran from the fifth
of may to the ninth of May attracted
nearly 10 million players eclipsing the
beta player numbers for games like star
wars battlefront and destiny have you
played either game have you played both
do you think a clear rivalry like this
only ends up hurting the customers let
me know in the comments or come and find
me on Twitter I'm at how not to draw
thanks for watching and for all your
gaming and entertainment news keep it
gamespot